[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
okay and our viewers are very smart they
really watch the show carefully and they
when they think they find a mistake they
let us know so far many challengers 0
winners we don't make mistakes
sorry ok
well tonight a fan with the YouTube
handle monk er 59 says he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
during a recent piece called new video
games hey Conan who did a bit about new
video games where you showcased some
games that were soon to be released to
the public however the very first game
you displayed a super diabetic Mario
Brothers I just showed how mistaken you
are about the video game industry that's
right it's called super diabetic Mario
Brothers the Mario Brothers franchise
and all of its affiliations which super
diabetic Mario Brothers would fall under
our owned solely by Nintendo the game
you showed had to have been an Xbox 360
game because the case was that classic
transparent green color but Nintendo
games they're all in white cases you see
that's that's just what they are such as
this game alright and that's one two
white case and this one
[Music]
well I'm sorry
monk er 59 but you are dead wrong okay
you say the green ones are only used by
Xbox I can prove that's not true believe
it or not I have footage of a secret
meeting between Nintendo's CEO can we
just pretend this is true you're gonna
get behind me on this or not the show's
free all right okay and it's
air-conditioned anyway I can prove
that's not true because I have footage
of a secret meeting now you're over
doing at a secret meeting between
Nintendo's CEO and two of his VPS from
earlier this year let's take a look
and another cost-cutting move here in
Nintendo we're gonna start packaging our
games in these old green boxes we bought
on eBay those are those are Xbox
containers yeah this is a bad idea our
Nintendo customer will notice oh come on
no one's gonna notice except for
hardcore dweebs like this one or this
one and especially this one why do you
have pictures of nerds on your desk
why are you fired get out you two
[Applause]
[Music]
we're talking about something anyway I
guess we went again and the challenge
still stands we do if you think you've
spotted an error on our show reported at
team koco.com slash haha I found an
error we will sort it out right here on
the air and we're always fair